hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from when readers Jackie who had a full
time job but had to take a big pay cut
and now has to pay off credit card
payments and a bunch of other debt and
wanted to start a business to make a
little bit more money and wanted my
advice on how to get started and you
know what to do next so Jackie sorry
about your situation could be an
opportunity though if you're creating
this new business what I would do in
terms of thinking about what type of
business to run I would look at what
you're really passionate about what you
really love doing and combine that with
where you think you can add a lot of
value to people so if you can you know
intersect those two things of what you
really love and where you can add a lot
of value to people's lives that's the
making of a great start for a business
next thing I would do is think about
starting a service-based business so
don't get into the product side
especially if you're already you know
cash crunched and you're trying to make
extra money you don't want your business
to be a drain on your caching and be
bleeding you instead of giving you money
so start a service-based business and I
would also think about building around
the customer so whatever business you're
starting again we're thinking about what
we're certain what we're really
passionate about and we're working out a
lot of value go out and start talking to
customers and see where you could
potentially help them out see what
challenges they have and offer your
services as a way to help them solve
those problems and when you have
customers paying you it's a lot easier
to go up to the next customer and go up
to the next customer and keep growing
your business so you're starting small
you're starting part time you still have
your job and slowly you build up
customer after customer after customer
build it around the problems that they
have and following what you're really
passionate about so Jackie I hope that
helps i know it's some general advice
but do you have more specific questions
now feel free to leave a comment below
the video everybody else i'd love to
hear your comments too and also if you
want to give the video a thumbs up they
always appreciate those so thank you for
watching and stay tuned for next episode